Oh many thanks Taryn anything's how  proximal if you come to the ship if  those the probability is well now  welcome to the EDC if you're hearing  this message it means you have what it  takes to be part of our team not many  people can say that EDC recruits are  independent smart and above all else  discreet this view screen will be one  source of intelligence updates using  clandestine technology on your mobile  you'll be able to track monitor and  deploy campaigns around the world in  real time  your initiative and drive have gotten  you this far let's see if we can get you  through the next mission enemy presence  closing in on your position keep your  eyes open scrambler and Deadpool class  Nevada closing in  enemies are flanking you drop a raise to  defend yourself shield canopies deployed  hostiles neutralized good job